[Music]
hello, how are you, I greet you, andrés gonzález
with his brief information for today, Thursday
, May 13, this week, students from
fixing universities around the
state will be celebrating their graduation
today, for example, in the video, I organize
this ceremony in person for the
graduates of the year.  2020 2021
students will celebrate this year outdoors
this will be today tomorrow and saturday at
sam boyd stadium on friday there will be a
ceremony dedicated to the
2019 2020 graduates who have waited over a
year to walk the stage and
receive their degree  due to the pandemic
and if you want to have a unique experience
to receive the vaccine against the young
19 a clinic will be available for
only one day at the iconic
welcome to las vegas' sign the
facer and jansen vaccines will be distributed at
this site beginning the  7 pm
on May 24 there will be food in the
parking lot of the harley
davidson dealership and even a private photographer  ar
to record this unique moment
and good news for
76 fans this tv show is coming back to
las vegas because we saw the
leads last night as they signed
the series among them are
georgia fax and william peterson in their
original roles some fans will
remember  former
newscaster paula franco she was
participating in a scene
now we turn to the weather forecast there
will be some laughs today with a
sunny sky and temperatures are expected to be
around 90 for the weekend
however temperatures will continue to be in
the range of  80 in the valley for a few
days and they will go up to almost 100 for the
next week happy Thursday I am
andrés gonzález and this was the
informative envelope of indies now in Spanish
[Music]